Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn his time for the
Monday morning podcast for Monday, uh,
August 8th,
2016 let me move close to the mic there.
Try not to have it on my chest so
you don't to listen to me breathing.
I know it's been an issue last
couple of podcasts, but like I said,
I'm out here on the road and the little
mix of that I use is a piece of shit.
And even if I have an adapter for
some reason it seems to blow up. Um,
it probably didn't, I probably
plugged into the wall and I fucked up.
But who knows.
So I am in a,
as an American would say Edinburg. I don't
know how to fuck they say in Scotland.
I just did a show,
believe it or not,
I'm at like a quarter to four
in the afternoon out here.
I have shows at three 45 and 1130.
I don't know why I thought it was
cause I signed on late to the festival.
I have no idea,
but I'm going to tell you man,
it was a fucking great time. It
was a great time. Look at that.
I just got a message here. All right. Um,
let me shut this fucking thing off.
Uh,
all right. So anyways, so I'd,
yeah, I just did a show. I
got to tell you, I loved it.
I'm sitting there the whole time going
over there, being this cranky fucking,
you know, little showgirl, right.
I was in Amsterdam last night,
which is a great show. So
today I'm flying, I land,
I get to the fucking hotel. Hotel
isn't ready, you know, as always,
that's how my travel
always gets put together.
They never let me sleep that extra
hour and a half. They're always like,
let's get them up and get them
to the next fucking shitty.
God forbid he misses his show.
And then you always get,
I always end up landing before
the fucking rooms ready.
And I know what you think of. Well, Bill,
why don't you have you were somebody
call ahead and ask for an early check in.
I'll tell you why.
Because I don't live my life that way.
I live my life moment to fucking moment.
That's,
I try to,
because if I look too far down the road,
I have a panic attack and I start getting
overwhelmed and depressed and I just
started going like, it's just flying
by, I'm going to die. So, all right.
It's not worth contemplating your own
mortality just to get a fucking early
check in.
I would rather walk in and then be like,
what do you mean the room isn't ready?
But I have a show.
Right. And throw a big
fucking hissy fit. Admit it.
That's what everybody wants
to see. Um, oh, you know,
something I forgot to
mention. Um, you know,
visiting John Bonham's grave,
the legendary John Bonham, uh,
and paying my respects such
a quiet, peaceful place. Um,
I was just looking up some stuff on it.
I forgot to mention this.
I don't know if they've
raised enough money,
but there's a group of people trying
to make a statue around his hometown.
It's the Bonham memorial fund. And, um,
I've been trying to reach
out to them to see if,
if they were able to raise the funds
or whatever, but, uh, you know,
with all these fucking bullshit
charities out out there, you know,
um, hopefully this one's legit.
I'm sure it is. But I, you know,
it's a pretty fucking cool thing if I
could drive you guys that way for John and
rebond bottom statute, I think that would
be, that would be a, that would be great.
At least I don't know,
something I would like. So, um,
if anybody knows somebody
connected with that fund,
I tried to send them an email.
I didn't try to,
I sent them an email and I checked
one day to see if they got back to me.
I didn't see anything from them and
I'm really bad at checking email,
so I'm worried that I'll never
check again. Um, but, uh,
I don't know. Somebody knows
somebody connected with it and uh,
if you can get some information,
send it to the podcast has sent it to me.
Hopefully I'll fucking see it.
And if they're coming up short,
I would love to send some money and make
a donation myself abso-fucking-lutely
towards it.
Um,
couldn't think of anybody more fitting
as far as I'm concerned as a performer.
Right. Um, all right, so
plowing ahead. So, um,
yeah,
so I had a three 45 show today
and I absolutely fucking love it.
I went over there and
I'm just thinking like,
Jesus Christ this [inaudible] give
me a bunch of blue haired old ladies.
The fuck has a comedy show
at three 45 in the afternoon.
We'd reminded me of when I was on my way
up and I was paying my dues and I was
humble and I treated my fellow human
beings with respect as opposed to now,
like I just sorta room service and like
the water wasn't in a glass bottle and I
slapped it down to the ground and I said,
how dare you,
I'm from the United States of America
right now. I didn't do that anyways.
My humble beginnings,
as I was coming up,
we used to do these things at colleges
and they will call newness. You know,
I got a nooner it fuck head stayed or
whatever and it was basically you did
stand up,
you know,
anywhere from fucking 11 in the morning
to like one in the afternoon and you had
no idea what the fuck you
we're going to walk into.
I mean you knew it was most likely going
to be one of the most humiliating hours
of your life.
You knew like 90% chance that most of
the people in the cafeteria or in the
hallway area or whatever,
had no idea that there was even going
to be a show guaranteed that whoever's
bringing you up on stage
is not in show business.
So it's going to be a horrible
fucking intro. The whole thing.
I remember I used to just go on stage
right before I would go on stage.
I would just look at my watch and I would
always think an hour from now this is
going to be over.
Okay.
No matter how awful this gets,
no matter how humiliating this gets,
an hour from now I'm going
to be back in the rental car.
I'm gonna drive away from this school
and I don't have to ever think about this
fucking show again, but I
will have the money. Okay.
And whatever that pay me,
they probably shouldn't give me twice
that amount because I blew probably at
least three times that on fucking therapy.
You have to go in through those things.
But that's how I always used to.
That's how I used to always think it.
And uh,
if you guys think I'm angry and negative
now you should've seen me back then
when I, I didn't even understand.
I'm actually, I'm not negative now,
but I was way,
way more angry and I was
really fucking negative.
I was always waiting for the other shoe
to drop before, I don't know, I just,
okay,
I don't,
I read a bunch of fucking books and
shit and I was able to come out of it.
And I know I trash a lot of
shit here on the podcast,
but I like to think
that when I give advice,
you know, you can hear the
twinkle in my eye. You know,
it starts to sound like Christmas
when I tried to help somebody up.
Maybe I'm not,
maybe I'm the same way,
but I mean back then I will at least I
wasn't even fucking aware of fucking nuts.
I was. And uh, I would just
go up there and I was just,
I dunno if somebody said anything.
I just tried to chop their fucking head
off and a lot of times they weren't
being mean and I ended up creating the
fucking hostile situation between me and
the crowd that I didn't want.
I wanted it to be an easy gig.
So why would you go up there and smile
and be like, Hey, it's great to be here.
You know, blah, blah, blah and try
to ingratiate yourself to the people.
You know why I don't know how to do that.
I don't know how to do that
because when I grew up,
I didn't see anybody doing that.
All right.
There's very few people from
where I'm from, from even fucking,
have you ever used the word ingratiating?
I'm day right now.
I have no idea how to spell it.
All right.
The first letter is either an I or an e.
Is it end gray? She, anyone
in, in, in Greece? I, I'm
going to go with [inaudible].
I'm gonna try to spell it right now.
Let's see what do we got here? Come on.
And Bill, I'm going to,
I'm going to close my eyes.
I N G R so it doesn't help
out in gray. C I a T. I n. G
come on one time. One time, get it right.
Oh fuck you.
Okay.
It's I N G R a. T. I. A. T.
I. N. G. I miss one letter.
Do you know what I mean? That's like
being off a degree in the space shuttle.
The next thing you know
you're on fucking Mars.
You know when you were trying to go to
a, I dunno, Jupiter will go with Jupiter.
Um, let me go back here. So anyways, um,
I was sitting backstage
waiting to go on and Ellen was,
the show was fucking tremendous
and I know, and I was like,
why the fuck do I think that
was going to stink? This is why.
Because the last time I did shit like
that, nobody knew who the fuck I was.
No one knew there was a comedy
show. This shit. I went there.
It was people that listen to the podcast.
They wanted to go there and they
knew it was a show. So now I'm like,
holy fuck.
I want to do fucking quarter to four
in the afternoon shows from now on.
Fuck this. Eight, nine, 10
o'clock at night. Shit, dude,
if I could have my day over,
ah,
that would be the greatest thing ever.
I want to become the 11:00 AM comedian.
Be like back in the day. I'll become
a morning person again. Who's kidding?
Who with all my fucking demons, I can't
sleep on four hours a night. Anyways,
my wife says,
I always have a fucking look on my
face of worry or I'm thrashing about.
I'm a fucking mess.
She goes,
the only time you fucking sleep peacefully
is when you get fucking drunk. Uh,
but then I snore. I mean, as I've
told you before, like I'm a fucking,
my wife says sync putting
up with me. So anyways. Um,
I would fucking love to do that.
You know,
if I had it like a show Friday
night in a show Saturday night,
if I can move them up
till like four in the afternoon.
Right.
Even if I did a two hour show,
I would be done at six
o'clock at night fucking rap.
And then at that point
I can go to a ball gag.
I can go see all the shit that I miss.
That would be perfect.
But it sucked for the four of us coming
up to see me because they'd have to
leave work early.
Maybe the Saturday night show,
I dunno, probably wouldn't work
people to use the other way,
but I have to tell you, like
I, if I didn't have this
1130 show to do right now,
like I like the level of excited.
I feel like, you know what?
I feel like right now, I feel like
I got a day off from, from school.
You know when you were a kid,
except I got that other one hanging over
my head at 1130. Oh God. It was great.
The people were fucking sober.
It was tremendous.
I know a number of comics
that do, like they, they,
there's a few comics who worked totally
clean and they do like afternoon shows
and um, I've always pictured
it being like, Oh God, you
must meet. See afternoon,
the sun's out. You did. You,
you must have to be like
beyond clean and wholesome.
And I gotta tell you, I just
did my fucking act. You know,
it's hard as I would have done it at
night and it worked fine. So I dunno,
I might've accidentally
stumbled onto something,
so sorry about clearing my throat every
five seconds. I just been, you know,
working every night, uh, doing this tour
and I gotta tell you, man, this is one,
this has been one of the best
tours of my career as far as, uh,
just the people showing up and the venues
that I've gotten to play when I last
left. Yes. Um,
when I checked in on you on Thursday,
I was,
I just gone to Bristol,
England,
the place where those ants were crawling
all over the chocolate cake and I had a
great time.
They're great show.
And then I went to a legendary Manchester,
England,
and um,
I gotta be honest with you.
That was the one out of all the
shows that I'm doing on this tour.
That was the one that I was
concerned about. I'm like, all right,
this is Manchester man,
United man city,
the fucking hooligans
and all of this shit.
And the only thing I knew about
them was that book that I read.
I can't remember if I brought
this up Thursday. I read
that book among the thugs,
whether there was an old, uh, American
journal journalist who was considered old.
He was in his thirties.
He was considered a good Giza and
he somehow infiltrated them and,
and just some of the violence that they
fucking talked about when they were over
there. I remember some of the
fucking stories. Do you know,
there was something that,
I'm not saying that this was
specifically done in Manchester,
but Manchester was only the,
the only soccer city that I
knew, I didn't even know,
or football as they say,
like Liverpool to me was the Beatles.
And meanwhile,
the Liverpool team before
Manchester started,
went on their run up until about 1990
and one more championships than anybody.
And I had no fucking
idea. Um, but anyways,
I guess one of the things he's fucking
hooligans used to do is they'd have a box
cutter or a raise or Assam shit.
Right.
And they'd get so fucking sharp that
they'd come up behind the supporter of
another club.
Uh,
when they were standing up waiting to
go in and they'd slash right across your
ass, um, you know,
horizontally and it was so sharp,
it would go right through your fucking
pants slash right across both butt cheeks.
All right.
And was done so quick.
By the time the person realize what was
going on in the other person had taken
off and is the fucking thing,
it,
it cut deep enough that you needed
stitches to close it. All right.
And the reason why they did it there was
so then while you're waiting for like a
week, I'm trying to remember when
I used to get stitches in it,
depending on how bad it was or what,
anywhere from three,
four days to like a week later
they took it out. Basically,
you couldn't sit down or
you'd pull the stitches out.
So you can't sit down, you can't sleep
on your back and God for, you know,
you gotta take a dump
your dough.
And I was thinking you'd have to get
in that, you know, that yoga position,
that table position. It's
basically, you know, I dunno,
just imagine trying to make
yourself a table facing up.
You'd have to do that and put a bucket
underneath you and then you can't tell me,
uh, God, there's, you know, during
the process of that it's not hurting.
The fucking misery of
that is unbelievable.
And I mentioned that to
somebody when I was up there.
And then they talked about,
another thing that they would do
is they realize that, you know,
if he cuts someone with a box car did,
they could stitch it up.
So then what they did was they put two
blades side by side that were far enough
apart that when you slash the person,
there wasn't any way for
the doctor to stitch it up.
They had to like glue it up
because the space was too big.
Just some fucking sadistic shit.
So anyways,
other fucking really gross things that
I read. So in my head I was just like,
Jesus Christ, this is like, I'm going,
this is gonna be like a Philly
show with box cutters. And um,
it was the exact opposite. It was
great. And I gotta be honest with you,
it felt like a show in like Boston.
Like I really felt some sort
of weird connection with, uh,
the sound of the crowd's weird.
Every crowd sounds a little bit different.
And, uh, they had that working
class, blue collar, you know,
sucker punched in a bar fucking vibe,
you know,
that I grew up at now, I was no tough
guy. I just grew up there. So I saw,
I used to see the violence and try to
get the fuck away from it. Like I said,
I basically fought other kids up
until about sixth grade, you know,
I had a bunch of baby fat, so I was
like, I was in a higher weight class.
Then all of a sudden I liked thinned out
and I was one of the scrawny your kids.
And then my fighting career abruptly
ended with a couple of ass kickings and I
was like, all right, why don't we
try being funny from here on out? So,
mmm.
After that, people just
kept getting bigger and the
injuries got worse. You know,
people laying on the floor of the bar
is someone's repeatedly kicking him in,
the head, teeth get knocked out. And I
was just like, yeah, you know, I, uh,
I don't want to do that to somebody and
I definitely don't want that done to me.
So, uh, I'm gonna Start, you
know, I utilize my footwear
a lot when I was younger,
walking away, running away, skipping
away, whatever the fuck I had to do,
not interested. So anyways, um,
after I did a Manchester,
then I had my big shows in
London, you know, and uh,
at the Hammersmith Apollo and I went
and I was talking about all the,
all the bands that had played
in Manchester. And, uh,
one of the guys working on the
tour used to uh, run that building.
And he saw everybody from when
the stone roses first came out,
red hot chili peppers, all those bands
from that era all played there. So,
um,
when I went to the Hammersmith One,
I decided to look up to see
who the fuck has played there.
I mentioned a few of them.
I thought it was Manchester on Thursday,
but it was actually the one in London,
like Ziggy stardust,
that character David Bowie,
I thought he retired at the Manchester.
Paulo was London. And also, um,
iron maiden did, they're
a, they had a live,
mmm.
See if I can find it
here. What is it, beast
over Hammer Smith.
Um,
and that was in 1982 was sold out show
on that stage and one of the coolest
fucking things ever. That's
when Clive Burr, who shares
my last name, I should say,
I share it with him. Um, he
actually played there, um,
just fucking amazing drummer.
But I went to look up all of these.
I hope I'm not boring you guys
with this ship, but this is,
this is the fucking history of
that place. All right. 1950s.
All right.
This is the Apollo in London,
19 on March 25th,
1958,
buddy Holly perform two shows
at the venue, the switchers,
last shows ever in the United Kingdom.
the 60s,
Tony Bennet with count Basie,
Ella Fitzgerald with Duke Ellington,
Louis Armstrong.
The Beatles did 38 shows over 21 nights.
It between 1964,
late 60 [inaudible] early
65 Johnny Cash and 66.
Eric Clapton with the yard birds.
Um,
uh, what else do we got? I'll just
kind of just fly through these here.
Queen Freddie fucking mercury, the
greatest front man ever. Elton John.
Oh God. There's a bunch of kids next
door. I hope you can't hear that.
Bruce Springsteen,
Neil young kiss made their
first UK appearances in
1976 they sold out two shows
in two hours. Genesis back when they
were like this prog rock band. Um,
Rory Gallagher,
Carlos Santana.
It just goes on and on and on and on.
There's another great one.
Black Sabbath played
there in [inaudible] 78
okay.
Jesus Christ. He's fucking
people trying to come in my room.
Black Sabbath played there
in [inaudible] 78 in there.
Their support at their
opening act was van Halen.
Touring on their first album.
Can Imagine fucking went to that show.
MMM.
I know. It just goes on and
on and on and on and on.
And you can scroll through all of this
if you just looked it up. Hammersmith,
Apollo,
London.
And then one of the coolest ones I saw
as far as standup comedians who perform
there in 2010 the great Billy Connolly
played there is fucking guy sold out 20
shows from July 5th to July 31st.
Oh,
by the way,
led Zeppelin when they announced that
they were going to have their reunion.
MMM,
well I'm sorry, a press conference
for the premiere of Celebration Day.
They did it there. So, uh,
in 2012 talk to the press,
that's how big their press conferences
or it's like most people's, you know,
concerts. So there's a picture of plant
page and John Paul Jones on stage.
It's pretty fucking killers. So anyways,
all right, I'm done geeking out here,
but I want to thank everybody
who came out to those shows. Uh,
the first night was, uh, was amazing.
The light was a little bit
in my eye on the first night,
so I couldn't quite see anybody and
they kind of fixed it the second night.
And as great as the first night was,
the second night might have been
one of the best shows I've ever had.
And I remember thinking before I
went out there, you know, I'm like,
you know, who knows if I
ever get to come back. So
make it count dog, go, go out there
like a fucking pussy or something.
I forget what happened.
And a number of people were talking about
all the heckles I got during the show.
It that did, it did not
even remotely bother me. Um,
I didn't find any of them to be
malicious or anything like that.
I just feel like I say a lot of dumb
shit when I'm on stage and it just,
I just feel like, you know, it makes
people want to like yell some shit. Um,
so anyways,
I got to tell you guys about the fucking,
I'm going to do it. Well, I'll read
a few advertisements here and, uh,
when I'm done stuttering over these,
the live reads,
I got to talk to you about like during
this time of the year in London,
um, a bunch of, uh,
Arabs come in to vacation
who have like tons,
like basically as far as I could tell,
limitless amounts of money and they're
coming in from the Middle East because
it's just so fucking hot.
So they take holiday [inaudible] out
here in London and they fly in on a cargo
plane. All of their supercars. I,
the only reason why I found this
out is because I've, you know,
I've never seen it. I was like, is there
a car show here or something like that.
And they would, then I just
started asking around. I mean,
just one fucking Lamborghini,
one Ferrari crazy Mercedes at fuck it.
You know what? Fuck the advertising.
I've got to tell you about this shit.
Like
I've never seen anything like it.
It was like four.
Okay.
Ferrari, California. Is that
the spiders? Uh, the, uh,
and then all these crazy colors like
this one fucking dude over there.
Look first, let me just read about
how they get their shit there,
if I can find it. Oh, you stupid cunt.
Bill. Did you really just mess that up?
Hang on. I gotta hit pause. I don't
want to fuck this up. Oh No, I haven't.
I have it here. Okay, here it is. Um,
okay.
So you know, all these, these, uh,
people at the hotel was saying no, these,
these people come in, they fly their cars
in and all that. And I was just like,
Jesus, they fly their fucking car,
like ship them in or whatever by boat.
Like how much would that cost?
So it says, uh, you know,
there's a website here
revealed how Arab playboys fly.
There's supercars in the
London on chartered a cargo
jets for the trifling sum
of 20,000 pounds per vehicle.
Um,
yeah,
20 quid,
whatever the fuck they say.
Cars are flown distances of around 3000
miles in planes such as Qatar Airways,
Airbus, [inaudible],
Lamborghini's, Ferrari's,
Mclaren's among vehicles
recently in Knightsbridge area,
which is the really ritzy
area or posh as they say. Um,
and the owners are usually here
only for a couple of weeks.
Dude, this is like a level of
fucking wealth that, you know,
I haven't seen it. I'm not saying that,
you know, it doesn't go on in my country,
but this, this, it was
fucking jaw dropping.
So basically I'll send
the link for this thing.
I mean these guys do not fuck around.
These are just some of
the sickest rides ever.
And then what I love is there's this
one guy, yeah, he's a Lamborghini.
There's a yellow one,
there's a grey one.
I didn't know what this other one's
like a McLaren or is that a Ferrari?
And they, and then this is the thing,
because they can all afford them.
They're trying to trick them out.
So there's looks unique.
This guy is some sort
of spider webs going on,
which is horrific to anybody who
ever considered buying that car.
Like why would you ruin that? Why would
you do that to that fucking work of art?
They look through their hooking these
fucking things up the way. You know,
those kids would drive the drifters
and shit. You know what I mean?
Or people drove hot rods.
What always have that.
Who's that guy is the guy used to do
all the fucking artwork on those things.
You know what I mean? And
those are like cars, you know,
that the kids could afford it to,
to like fix them up.
These are like some of the
richest people in the planet.
They do that to Ferrari's Lamborghini's.
So there's this one fucking guy,
okay.
He has all of,
he's like becoming famous because he flew
like six of his fucking cars over and
they're all like done in
like this mirror gold.
It's like,
I gotta be honest with you.
It's like the gaudiest thing I've
ever seen in my life, but it's,
it's fucking hilarious on,
on another level. Hang on.
All right,
so I found the guy here.
This guy's not even trying to be famous
or anything. I'd always doing it.
So Saudi billionaire Turkey Been
Abdula is the man behind the fleet of
incredible golden supercars currently
touring wealthy parts of London.
Okay,
dude, this kid, he looks
like he's like fucking 23
all right, these are the
pictures. All right, he's got,
this looks like a Lamborghini,
you know,
they're all the exact same
colored gold and you know,
it's funny as they get pictures of them
flying in their private jet and they're
doing that stupid piece
sign, Yolo thing, right? Set.
They're dressed in like the
traditional, you know, the steel,
the Saudi Arabian head gear that they
were like, it's all fucking white.
And then on top looks like that
traditional, a Betty Crocker tablecloth.
They got that with the
Lebron James Headband on,
right love and life in this private
jet. You know, they didn't rent it.
They probably own it. Right?
Then he's got another one.
This looks like a fucking one of those,
either a range rover or Mercedes truck.
And this is the greatest thing.
Custom Interior, all gold. And in
the driver's seat there's it Cheetah.
Uh, every car is like
350 fucking grand. Yeah.
You know, you ever seen that truck, this
six wheel Mercedes, it's got six wheels.
If going to be careful, these kids next
door, it's got fucking six wheels on it.
There's no fucking reason to have
this truck ever. I mean, the thing is,
I mean it's, it's incredible.
Fucking thing is incredible.
He's got one of those in gold. Oh.
And that's where he keeps his Cheetah.
Evidently, I'm just scrolling
down. He's got a range rover.
I mean, they had gaudy. I gotta I
dunno. Then he does him in black.
That kind of fucking cool looking.
So anyway,
so there's a bunch of people that fucking
can't stand it, you know, of course.
You mean you have one of those cars,
everybody's going to hate you if you got
fucking six of them and you're getting
them, you know, and they look like
the grilled member, those, those,
those fucking grills they used to
make, uh, those guys in Houston,
when that wrapper Paul Wall, I think he
would, he had a line in those things,
right? Remember how fucking like,
just in your face, God, he, that was,
but that was just teeth, you know?
So he had to make them laugh first,
which is a really difficult thing to do
with the rapper. You know what I mean?
The second they smile, their album
sales, they dropped tremendously.
So it's very rare that she
got him to smile. So was God,
he used they word it wasn't that
bad, right? There's no way to,
there's no way to look away from
these fucking cars. 20. He was.
So I'm walking down the street right
in London and I'm just looking at the,
all these cars. It was like a fucking
car show, man. It was amazing.
So there's this typical fucking,
you know,
showy jerk off in this Lamborghini,
not a gold one. And he's,
he's in like stop and go traffic.
And the entire time he's in
stop and go traffic, he's just,
he's just revving the engine one.
Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, whoa, Whoa, whoa.
I can't do the high pitch.
You don't,
you don't those supercars how
crazy they are. Right. And uh,
I'm trudging along in this humid air
and shit with all these Londoners,
right in this fucking ladies. The guys
going is sitting there going like, Whoa,
whoa, Whoa, whoa. Do what? All
that stuff. Uh, she just goes, oh,
stop it.
I was fell down on the sidewalk at left
and that's the first time I thought like,
that's what made me research it going
like, like I've always, you know,
after the 50th Ferrari went by
and there wasn't a car show,
I was starting to sense that
there was something going on here.
But I just thought that these were
just super, I was like, wow. I mean,
there's a lot of money in London.
These guys are not fucking around.
Who the fuck would live in London? You
got the tube, you got all these taxis.
I mean, like it'd be like, hold on a
Lamborghini and you'll live in Manhattan.
You're like, why? Why? That's
just a disgusting level of
wealth. So I was just like,
man, these people are, uh, they're
crushing it over here in London.
But I guess it's just, um, this
group of people that comes over.
Okay,
dude, you got to look this kid up.
This kid cannot be more than like,
I dunno, 23, 24, dude,
he's got a gold Rolls Royce. He's got
a Bentley. I gotta be honest with you.
He knows his fucking car, the six wheels
Mercedes is fucking with ticketless.
Um, I know a lot of people are, you know,
it's blood money. It's this, it's that.
Yeah. You know, you're, you're
right. But whatever, you know,
it's fun to look at and you know,
something just being someone who
likes to go on stage in life.
I like to entertain people,
but it's also really fun to annoy people
and the fact that these people are
coming there and they're driving
around in their fucking cars. Sorry,
that just slid down the
pill. Sorry. They're driving
around in their fucking cars.
They're annoying. You know, making that
lady go, Ugh, stop it. It was just,
it was hilarious to me. So I'll send a
link to that stuff. Um, and with that,
with, with, um, all of that babbling here,
let me get 'em me read some advertising
here. I just started the people laughing.
Next door is,
I imitated the revenue of the engine.
So I don't know if they're laughing at me,
they're probably not cause they would
have heard me curse by now. All right.
Blue Apron, everybody. All right. Not
all ingredients are created equal,
fresh, high quality ingredients
taste better and are better for you.
So it's important to know where your food
comes from. The less than $10 per meal,
Blue Apron delivers seasonal recipes
along with proportion degradents to make
delicious home cooked meals.
Blue Apron knows that when you
cook with incredible ingredients,
you make incredible meals.
So they said the highest quality of
standards for their community of artisanal
suppliers in family run farms,
fisheries and ranchers.
I didn't know that that existed anymore.
Third corporations bought all of them up
and just said that they were artisinal
suppliers. Um, whether it's
Japanese ramen noodles,
wild caught Alaskan salmon
or heirloom tomatoes,
blue apron is bringing you the best.
MMM.
I was just going to ask what isn't all,
all salmon's wild?
Is it not wild if you have it in
your fish tank and your house?
But then it was like, no
wait, they got manmade salmon.
They make it like porridge.
Um, new recipes are created weekly
and are not repeated within a year.
Choose your meals with a variety of
recipes or let blue apron culinary team
surprise you.
Customers customize your recipes
each week based on your preferences.
Choose delivery options to fit your needs.
There's no weekly commitment so you
only get deliveries when you want them.
Each meal comes with a step by step,
easy to follow recipe card
and pre portioned ingredients
and can be prepared in
40 minutes or less. Um, all right,
you'll love how good it feels,
how great it takes to create a credible
home cooked meals with blue apron.
So don't wait. That's blue apron.com/bar
blue apron. A better way to cook.
All right.
Dollar
Shave Club. Everybody. Oh Geez. Is there,
do all the fucking shave club?
Do you go to Wisconsin when you
face over there? Alright. Um,
dollar shave club.com delivers amazing
razors right to your door for third of
the price of what the greedy
razor corporations charge.
That means when you
joined dollar Shave Club,
you can afford to shave with a
fresh blade anytime you want,
which feels fantastic. You know what it's
like, it's like being in a relationship.
And the second she gives you shit,
you kicked her out the door and
you get a brand new one coming in.
It's just like that.
It's like having an a limitless amount
of horse walking through your door except
their razor blades. You get first class
shave when you use the executive blade,
and that's without even
hurting your wallet.
And when you use the executive with
their doctor cabbies easy shea.
Yeah,
the blade just gently glides
for the smoothest shave ever.
Shave butter isn't your
average shave cream.
It's a unique conditioning formula
with high quality natural ingredients,
gradients leaving your skin
unbelievably soft and smooth.
Now's a great time to join dollar
Shave Club, new members, uh,
who buy a tube of shave butter.
Get a month of the executive
razor for absolutely free.
Take advantage of this
special offer today.
It's available by going to dollar shave
club.com/bird. That's dollar shave club.
Calm slash. Bar. All right,
let's do two and two. We'll
get back to the shit, right?
Will we, I hope we will. All right.
Continuing on for 34 minutes. Very
nice. Perfect. Perfect. Perfect.
So, um, I actually got to spend a
day in London, which was great. I um,
cause I was there for two nights and uh,
and I also finally got to
drive and see a lot of England,
absolutely gorgeous country.
And um,
so Hyde park is like their central park
and I just went in there, walked around.
I always look at Royal Albert Hall Cause
I'm telling you one of these days I'm
going to play there, right? I'm going
to do a show there. God willing,
if not, I'm going to see a show
there, but if I do play there,
I can guarantee fucking tee you.
I'm going to rent a drum
kit again during the day.
I already talked to the promoter,
I was like, can I rent a drum kit?
Can I go in there,
put on some headphones and just fucking
play to led Zeppelin because that was
one of bottoms.
I Dunno,
I think it's some of the greatest
live footage of him ever.
Is there a performance, a Royal Albert
Hall? And um, and he was like, Oh yeah,
absolutely.
No problem mate.
So that's definitely a
bucket list thing for me.
So I always go there and I just forget
about dreaming about playing that place,
just to look at it. If you
Google a picture of, um,
Royal Albert Hall, it's just,
um, it looks like it's something out
of the Roman Empire. I know it's only,
it was made in like the 1850s
or sixties or something. Uh,
but it's just an absolutely
incredible, incredible venue. And,
uh, I you that time, I'm a couple,
I don't know when it was like
2009 or 10 or something like that.
I took a tour of it with Nia.
Nia didn't want to go cause she
said it's gonna be boring as shit.
And we got there and
it was boring as shit.
But then when we went to go check out,
like they brought us out on the mezzanine
level and they got to sit down and one
of the suites,
and right as we was sitting down,
like the London Philharmonic was a,
was like practicing for
that night's performance.
And it was like they were waiting for us,
like right as we sat down,
they started playing and it was one of
the most beautiful things I ever heard in
my life. Nia immediately. So
she puts a hand over,
a mouth starts tearing up and all that.
And all I could think was like,
you know what,
now would have been a great
time to ask you to marry me.
That would have been the, but how the
fuck did I know that was going to happen?
So instead I waited till we went to
white castle, now can, um, anyways,
so then last night I got what I got
to walk around all a Hyde Park and um,
okay,
truly incredible that,
that does just the sheer size of that.
And they have a bunch of parks,
um,
more so way more so than a Manhattan
is as far as like the size of him and
everything. And uh, just a really,
and it actually seemed like there
was enough space for everybody. Um,
and then after that I went over to
Amsterdam. The next day flew out.
Uh, oh Jesus. I forgot the whole
other part of the story. Sorry.
My brain is all even more all over the
place because I've been flying all over
the place, so, and I just did a show in
the afternoon and I'm still jet lagged.
I don't even know what
the fuck I'm doing here.
So I apologize if this is more scatter
brained than usual. But, so after my,
my, um, my second show,
okay.
In London, um, I was just, uh,
I could not have done a better job on
that one. I was so fucking thrilled.
Thank Christ. And then, uh, I
deliberately booked myself in a hotel.
I usually stay wherever
the fuck I don't care,
but this hotel actually had a cigar
bar in it and I learned that from Cigar
Aficionado. They got this thing called
places to smoke. So if you're traveling,
just look it up and they will tell you the
place to go. And I went there with, um,
with the person who was the tour manager
and it was just me and him and we went
in there. It was funny when we first
came in, they had, they were like, oh,
we're sorry, we don't have
any, we don't have any seats.
Because we walked in looking like
a couple of fucking rubes you know,
and my baseball hat on and shit
and all sweaty from the show.
We just look at two fucking
assholes and you know,
in there were all these gorgeous Arab
women and all those fucking, you know,
you know,
that whole fucking scene was going.
I don't know if those checks were from
London trying to meet the guy in the
golden car, but at this point I was
so caught up in the fucking soap op.
It was like watching a reality show.
Like how that isn't a reality
show is fucking beyond me.
Somebody needs to make
that a fucking show.
It's literally like fast and
loud without building a thing.
Meets like the fucking real
housewives meet. But there guys,
you know,
I don't know big brother or something.
I want to see them talking about
what it's like to be that rich.
I want to see the whole fucking process
of how they got those fucking cars over
there. Did they give a fuck that people
hate on them for having those cars?
How do they deal with women coming in?
Because I,
you've got to fucking fleet a gold cars.
I don't give a shit who the fuck she is.
Well that's not true.
But uh,
there's a sizable amount of women that
will just blow you just so they can look
at themselves sucking a dick in
the fucking shine of that car.
Okay.
If anybody in London ever
fucking make set show,
please text me a link cause I'm going
to watch every fucking episode I want to
see. I want to see the whole
thing. The riding over in the jets,
you know the whole thing,
the confiscating of the passports.
So you have the slave labor that builds
Dubai. I want to see the fucking,
I want to see the whole thing,
the pain, the sorrow, the whores,
the whole fucking thing.
Tremendous. Um, anyways,
where was I? I don't know where
I was. Oh. So we ended up,
so I just said things like, yeah,
we don't, I knew what he was doing.
He saw me coming in with
my stupid potato face,
all fucking sweaty from the show and
my dump, tiger woods beat up golf hat.
Then he was just like, game Saturday, so
we do not have any fucking bum Ba, ba,
ba Ba. And I was just
like, dude. I said, dude,
which really made him stop for a second.
I was like,
I booked myself in this hotel
specifically so I could smoke here.
Um, and he goes, well, the, you could
sit at the bar, maybe you did that.
So I fucking go upstairs, drop my shit
off. By the time I got downstairs,
they had a table because
I think the fucking, uh,
the tour manager guy said something
so you know, we are able to sit down,
you know, it was fucking hilarious.
Two, this is what's hilarious.
They were plenty of seats.
Okay.
Fucking assholes. You know, they saw me
coming in and looking like old sick Lee,
Ron Howard. They were like, fuck this
guy. This guy's not bringing in the ass.
So money in here. Yeah. Beat
it. Go get yourself a snow code.
You fucking freckled
mess. Um, oh, we're sorry.
You're spending money here. Okay. Yeah.
By the, well there's 40 empty two tops.
Where did they come from? Well, when
you went upstairs for two minutes,
all of a sudden everybody left. Um, so,
oh, it was the greatest. And the, the,
uh, the tour manager didn't smoke cigars,
but said he wasn't adverse to doing
it and a greatest feeling ever.
Right.
He sat down and he was smoking and he
was just going and he's gradually get
getting more and more into it.
And I was happy to see he was liking it.
Then I was also nervous like, fuck,
I just give somebody a cigar habit.
But he was just like, he's, I forget
what he's saying. This is brilliant.
This is lovely. And they go,
yeah, this is what it is.
Everybody thinks it's like smoking his
cigarette. Cigarette smokers are animals,
they're junkies.
They run outside in the rain.
They're fucking standing next to the
dumpster. Is this sitting on stoops?
Animals sucking in into their lungs.
You know, I'm going need another one.
Need another one. Need another one? No,
no, just the Gar. It's for gentlemen.
You know, you sit down, you shoot the
shit, you break each other's balls,
you solve the world's problems. You
don't really, but you feel like you do.
It's fucking tremendous.
I guess it's Kinda like cocaine rights
and that would happen when you do cocaine.
You think everybody's a good shit and
then you figured out how to run the world.
Then you get all paranoid like a
dictator. And then, I don't know,
somebody overdoses and everybody
runs out of the room. Um, I dunno.
I always stayed out of that world.
All right, let's get to some, uh,
let's get to some questions
here. Um, for the week.
There's no fucking way that they're not
going to make a reality show out of that
they got to do. Unless those kids are so
fucking rich and by kids, no disrespect.
It's just I'm an old man. If you're
in your 20s, you're a kid to me. Um,
unless they're just so rich that
they don't want to bring any,
well that's stupid.
Don't want to bring attention to yourself.
You driving a fucking gold
mirrored car down the road.
Oh God.
It was tremendous. I cause
you know I drive a fucking
nine year old Prius. Right.
I was always envious of those
fucking people that would
do shit like that. Those,
hey look at me people, you
know, I would feel like the,
if I drove down the
street and one of those,
I would feel like the biggest fucking
tool ever. Like if I ever had a Ferrari,
the last thing I ever want to
do is drive it slowly by a cafe.
I would be so fucking self conscious of
people looking at me and then people I,
people would actually laugh at me,
they'd look at me and they would be in
a Ferrari still getting laughed at and I
just, I've had enough
pain in life. However,
okay.
If I ever had a Ferrari, if I was
out on the fucking open road, yeah,
I would have windows up.
I don't want anybody to see me cause
that really ruins the car if feel like,
oh my God, let's see this James
Bond looking guy in this car.
And then you fuck it,
see my red head and there
he must have a terminal
disease or something. How
the fuck did he get that car?
Um, all right, let me uh,
okay.
Let me read some of the questions
here for this week. Oh Jesus.
Did I even take that in? Copy
and paste them yet. What are you,
what's going on with you this week bill?
Your yummy crunchy or you're year,
you're all over the map. Yeah.
All right. Content. Content.
All right.
All right,
bill grading me as, keep forgetting to
have you announced the posters? Oh yeah,
the Madison Square Garden posters will
be on the website. Uh, this Wednesday,
um, when I played Madison Square Garden
I made all these fucking posters and I
didn't have a merge person and for some
reason I thought the venue was going to
handle it and nobody did.
So I had all these posters
made and shipped to Madison
Square Garden and I sold
like zero and then had to pay to
ship them all the way to fucking la.
It was a fucking, it was a fiasco.
So I have a couple hundred,
I don't even know how many of me, I
think I hadn't made like five, 500,
maybe four or 500 of them.
So I autographed all of them.
You know it's funny is I always keep one
poster for like the scrapbook and uh,
I wasn't paying attention
and I autographed all of
them. So now the only poster,
I have his signed by me so I'm not going
to get one cause I can't have a poster.
Sometimes a bill keep being you,
you know,
Bill, be stupid. So feel
like an asshole. Um,
you know, it's a continuing story
of me being an idiot. All right.
Minimize the crazy. All right.
Love the podcast. They'll,
I listened to it at the gym cause
it's really motivating. Not uh,
not really just good to hear someone
talking shit rather than listening to the
constant grunting and self
praise. You hear in gyms, uh,
I'm in Australia and I'm
in my early thirties,
and I need to break up with a crazy
chick. Oh Jesus. This is always difficult.
It's not difficult.
If I'll tell you right now,
the degree of difficulty is greatly
increased if you're living with,
they're obviously all right, if
you're not living with her, um,
I can tell you exactly how you do it.
All right?
And I would be, oh, I can't tell you.
I'd have to tell you to have
al Madrigal do it. Al Madrigal,
I should have him on the podcast.
He had the greatest fucking
way ever of breaking up with,
uh, with a girlfriend. And I
feel like it's his story to tell.
So now that I got y'all fucking
interest in ow fuck you.
I'll make up 40 and let me read
this real quick. Um, all right.
I need to break up with a crazy chick
and I'm hoping to minimize the property
damage or stocking that usually
comes along with the crazy, well,
why don't you do this? Why don't you
set up some security little cameras,
catch you're damaging your property.
And for once report a woman damaging a
guy's fucking property after a breakup
and maybe she liked,
you have to fucking pay for it.
All these videos of these chicks just
fucking just destruction of property does
not apply to a female. I don't
understand it. Anyways, he goes,
I would normally just do it in a public
place and then go into hiding for a few
weeks with all of my
possessions under lock and key.
But this is different this time.
It's different.
We've been together for a bit over
a year and when I first met her,
I thought she was perfect, but it all
changed about nine months into it.
Her sister in law was caught drink driving
with their 15 month old driver, uh,
daughter in the car.
And as a result,
the kid was taken off both parents until
one of them could prove to be a fit
parent. Oh my God. They took
it away from both of them. Wow.
All right.
Her brothers slash the kid's father
has always been a a fit parent,
but in Australia the authorities
have a preference for the mother.
So he had to go through the bullshit
to get his daughter back. Yeah.
Jason's every fucking lot
seems, uh, when this happened,
we put our hand up to take care of the
kid and the kid and the girl moved in
with me, um, for a bit over 12 weeks.
Having the kid around was fucking awesome.
And because of our work schedule,
I got to spend a lot of time with
the kid and loved every minute of it.
My girlfriend, however, it wasn't
very keen on it right from the start,
which made it pretty clear that we
want different things in the situation.
Also brought out the
crazy in a pretty big way.
She tended to be angry with me every
morning over shit that I couldn't do
anything about, such as her
job. And on top of that,
it became extremely jealous that
are ex had a new girlfriend.
Normally this would be the kind
of thing that would make me walk,
but we were looking after the kid.
Now the kid is back with their
father and it's time for the breaker.
I'm pretty sure she's the type of
crazy [inaudible] that would resort to
property damage for, for physical
violence. And I'm trying to reduce this.
The only issue I see aside from the crazy
is that she still has a few things in
my house and there are a few things
that belonged to the kid left here.
Portable cod clothes and
toys. Any strategies you
can think of would be great.
All right. You know what? You need the
Al Madrigal advice and he's not here.
This is our mantra goals.
This is his,
this is how he did it.
I'm giving him total credit here.
When al had to break up with a woman,
then he made the decision,
you know, when he, before he
went over to her apartment,
he would get a box and he would take
all of her belongings that were in his
apartment,
put him in the box.
Okay.
And then come over holding the box
and the woman opens the doors like what
the fuck? And then you immediately,
oh,
I think he already changed the locks too.
That's another thing to change
the fucking locks and uh,
which you can easily do.
Just what the different deadbolt,
that's just a couple of screws. Just do
that. And usually, you know, if that,
that's no big deal. Um, I
guess down belows a couple of
two, well it's no big deal.
Just change the fucking logs,
put everything in a box.
Then you go over to her place, you sit
down and you just say it's fucking over.
Blah Blah Blah.
They flip out,
they want to break something that are
in their house. That's it. Fucking over.
If I'm
okay,
if you have anything in
her apartment of value,
I would get that first and then I
would do the rest of it. But um,
there, there really should
be, you know, you know,
with all these things now that the
complaining that men do like anything from
fucking like mansplaining man
spreading and all that, the,
all these fucking feminist groups up and
down the fucking street about the shit
that we're doing.
Do any of them,
the ridiculous level of destruction of
property that women do to guys when,
when they break up with them or even if
they get caught fucking around. Okay,
you fucked around on you. That does not
give you the right to key the guy's car.
I mean, you can do it, but you should go
to jail. He should have to pay for it.
She'd go on your fucking record. And
the guys always just like, you know,
I just want to just make it go away.
Just make it,
they make like youtube
videos of themselves fucking
destroying property. Um,
so that might be something else you want
to look into do to this chick's crazy.
I would just go total CIA on him.
Go over there without her knowing.
Just take back leave.
Just first of all,
you're gonna have to leave some troops
behind. A couple of pairs of sneakers.
Got to go Willem to fall. Put tune here.
All right. But if you've got, you know,
if you've got some, I
don't know, I don't know.
Fucking iPad or some shit like that.
You need to grab that shit.
Get that shit the fuck out of there.
You have some sorta nerd friend or a
friend who knows a nerd. They wire like,
you know, you got fucking cameras and
all that shit. You got that going.
Change your fucking locks box up the shit.
Go over there.
Drop the fucking hammer.
MMM,
okay.
If you're worried that this woman's
going to get physical with you,
I would do that.
I would break up with her in a public
place because I don't know how it works in
Australia, but um, here in America,
a woman can take out a machete,
chop a guy's head off and then, uh,
sue the surviving family members for the
blister on her hand that she got when
she swung the fucking things
through his head. So, um,
good luck to you. Be careful and I hope
it all works out for you. All right.
Oh, for God's sake, I fucking 80 fucking
computers. You know what kills me?
I can't get him to do anything and then
you barely brush up against them and
everything fucking goes away.
What the fuck drives me
nuts. All right. All time.
Lows all time low. Sorry.
All right. Hey there,
Billy, with the Little Red Willie.
The fuck. Do you know about my Dick?
Dare you insulted like that.
Fucking, I challenge you.
I challenge you to a Instagram photo
up now. Okay. All right, dear bill. Uh,
I'm a 26 year old guy
living in Pennsylvania.
Until recently I was dating
my girlfriend of four years.
We bought a house together
six months ago. I, I,
what year?
26 year in Pennsylvania.
You're dating a girl for four years
and you bought a house together.
We had two Greg cats and couldn't be
happier with the fucking marry this girl
dude, or stop buying shit with her.
Sorry. Uh, about two weeks ago,
she went on a 10 day group hike,
hiking trip to Nevada with her
aunt and a bunch of random people.
When she came back,
I had a $300 purse waiting for her
as a welcome home gift. However,
after she thanked me for the gift, she
sat me down and said we needed to talk.
Oh yeah. She went on a hike, dude.
Which means she did some soul searching
and Dick Sucking no kid. So then we, uh,
she then told me she was breaking up with
me because she doesn't want to live in
the suburbs anymore or
work a desk job anymore.
She said she wanted to move out west and
become an outdoor adventure guide and
that it was a dream to work
in our country's national
parks and live and outdoor,
adventurous adventure type life. I asked
if there was another guy and she said,
no. She said she just needs to
find herself and follow her dream.
Um,
all right,
well up until now you can't get mad at
her if she's just telling you what she
wants and life as a regular
listener of your podcast,
I always hear you tell people
to follow their dreams.
So even though I was heartburn broken,
I supported her decision.
Okay,
we'll do it. I got to tell you,
that's really mature of you.
Most people would go and you know, most
guys would go into the fall, set up,
you fucking bitch. Uh,
the next day I saw her,
she got a text from a guy named
Zach. Uh Oh, we don't have any,
Zach's in our friends circle. Uh
Oh. While she was in the shower,
I snooped through her phone and
read her text message with Zack.
There were messages about how much they
missed each other and now she, she,
she couldn't wait to move out to Arizona.
They both sent each other naked pictures
and they talked about how much they
liked fucking each other
on their trip. It, boy,
she still doesn't know.
I've been through a phone.
So as of now I am at an all time low.
I have to sell my house
and lose a ton of money.
I lost my girlfriend to another guy.
She is also taking the cats and since
I can't afford an apartment by myself,
I'll be a 26 year old guy
living with my parents.
Well don't you get to half of the house?
Okay.
He goes in and to top it all off,
she's walking around with
that $300 fucking purse.
My question is how do I confront
her about the text message?
Do you have any advice
for me moving forward?
And was there ever a point
in your life that there,
that was an all time low and
how'd you get through with it? Um,
first of all, dude, uh, sorry,
you're going through all of that.
Here's the bright side. All right? Look,
if your girlfriend went on a fucking hike,
that's what she always wanted to do.
And when she went out there,
you know,
okay,
she gets all caught up
with this other guy.
Yeah.
She comes back and just immediately
breaks up with you. You know,
maybe she's letting you down a little bit
easier that she didn't meet this other
fucking guy. Why, why
add insult to injury.
Um,
okay.
But the fact that she accepted the purse,
She should've said,
I can't accept this.
She didn't have to tell you about
the fucking guy. I mean, what,
what second and do other than make
you feel fucking horrible. Um,
he's the bright side of
this, all of this. Okay.
The bright side is you're a fucking great
guy.
You're a solid guy.
You didn't get mad her or any of that
type of stuff you support in fucking dream
whip and uh, she kept the
purse, which means she's a cunt.
And I don't think this guy, Zach knows
what's going to hit him, you know?
But you know what? Zach might be
a dick. She's going out there.
She h you know what I mean?
W what, what are you going to
do? She wants to go out and go,
fuck some guy wears sandals on a
rubber raft. I mean that, that's,
that's her idea of a man than
you just gotta let her go. Um,
but the thing is you can't internalize
it like it had anything to do with you.
It had nothing to do with you. All
right? You just picked the wrong one.
But you know what, dude, I was
going to say, at least you didn't,
that you didn't have any kids.
You learn something.
Don't buy a fucking house with
somebody you're not married to. Okay?
You want,
you know,
100 fucking percent that this is the
person you want to spend your life with.
And they say that to you. You
know, hopefully then that line,
which is the difficulty of
fucking relationships, um,
then you go out and you buy a fucking
house with somebody. But Dude,
you're only 26 years old. You got
your whole life ahead of you. And, um,
I would bring up the fact that she was
with that guy, Zack, I think, I mean,
I dunno.
This is what you should do.
Yeah.
Okay.
Here's what you do. Just be
a total fucking gentlemen
and asked her if she likes.
Oh God.
Here we go.
Just sit her down and just ask her if
she likes to person all that. And right,
right before, this is the last time you're
going to see, uh, last time, you know,
you're going to ever see her just
right before she [inaudible] hey honey,
you know, good luck with your
dream and blah, blah, blah, blah.
You do your little bullshit hug.
And she walks away and go, oh honey,
one more thing. Hey, tell
Zach I said what's up?
And just shut the fucking door.
And then as she's walking away,
you just scream out. She a fucking oh,
um, no. Your each be finding, listen,
you just said you'd throw
Zach in the middle of it.
You could really have a lot of fun with
this and I'll tell you something right
now. No one knows more how much fun
you can have with it that a woman,
a woman knows how to fucking
like, I'm, I'm going to ruin this.
Women are really good at this. Guys
are just like, go, let's go fight.
Women know how to be like, Ooh,
I got this piece of information.
What is the perfect fucking way this
will do the most amount of damage?
What if you put it in the middle
of it? If you say, listen,
I just want you to know I'm
really happy for you and Zach.
You know you're going to be out.
That's too early. Really happy for you.
You going to be out there living your
dream and as much as I'm going to miss you
and everything,
I'm just so happy that you're have
the courage to follow your dream,
you know?
Yeah.
Oh, how do you do somewhere
in there, somewhere in there?
You just gotta you know,
you can be out there rafting, you know,
you can keep fucking Zach and, but no,
it's only to say for don't say
fuck. See, I'm gonna mess it up.
But you understand where I'm going
with that. She got to just put,
just put drop sack in the middle of it
and then do about two more sentences and
then just stop and just
stare at it and just,
just leave her in this stunned
silence of that moment.
MMM.
And then whisper in your ear so I didn't
have gifts with you and then you walk
away. Sorry. All right. That was creepy.
Anyways. All right. Amusement parks.
Hey Billy Bonzo a bozo. Sorry, Billy Bozo.
I thought it was a compliment to me.
He was actually insulting.
Just wanted to hear your take on amusement
park. Well, you're taking an amusement.
Parks are,
I went the other day with my girl and
just could not help but notice all of the
fucking animals around me from people
walking barefoot to the fat asses,
walking with their giant fucking
Turkey legs around the park.
I hope you guys can't
hear my stomach growling.
I haven't eaten all day to day cause I've
been eat. They've been eating so bad.
Trying not to fucking
eat a giant breakfast here anyways.
I was just disgusted or lunch,
I should say.
I was just disgusted you a fan of
going to an amusement park, whatever.
Go Fuck Yourself. No, I'm not.
They are. They are fucking,
yeah.
Animal magnets. Look, I don't
mind kids that go there,
but the fucking adults that go there,
some of the worst tattoos,
some of the worst bodies.
Some of the mouth breathe in fucking
morons. Like you go to amusement park.
That's right. Everybody who
can afford to go to Disneyland.
You're talking animals.
You're talking rides that don't work.
People get killed at those fucking
things. I swear to God, Dude.
It's like it's,
it's
okay.
It's a bump up from a carnival.
Okay.
But even carnivals aren't as bad because
I feel like a carnival, you have the,
the community,
it came to your town,
so there's a bunch of high
school kids seeing each other.
It's still kind of a fun thing,
but you just go to an amusement park.
It's just there any of
those fucking water parks,
any of that type of shit that is
just a white trash fucking magnet.
All right, that's my elitist
comment for the fucking day. Uh,
we got a couple more of these to read.
Let me a couple more questions and
let me just knock out these last two
advertisements here.
Advertisements, alright.
MVMT watches, uh, when you're, when you're
in your early twenties and thirties,
money can be tight if you're not careful.
Dressing well can drain your bank account.
Like spending four to 500 bucks in
a dispatch department store. Watch.
There's some brands out there charging
and same prices for watches than aren't
even worth it. Well, if you want
to look great when you go out,
but still have enough money to buy
him or her a drink, checkout movement,
watches.com um,
originally founded by two broke
college kids movement watches,
cut out the middleman and they're big
brand retail markups in order to give you
a stylish wash watch for an
affordable price movement.
Watches start at just 95 bucks
a watch this plot, mid store
quality for a fraction of the price.
You could buy one of these and
still go to amusement park. Uh,
they're sleek and minimalist minimalistic.
A modern twist on a classic style
movement has grown organically purely by
supporters like yourselves.
Go to MV empty watches.com/burr and
they'll give you 15% off your entire
purchase. That's MVMT
watches.com/bar last but not leastly.
Um, at least the lists. Um,
stamps.com everyone
chips to the post office.
It probably becomes second nature to you.
They seem easy because you've been doing
your mailing and shipping that way for
so long. But think about all the
hassles man. Drop in what you're doing,
driving. They're finding
parking, hitting an old lady,
looking around to see if anybody
saw you hiding the body waiting.
There's so much better ways to go.
Stamps Dot coms is the way stamps.com
is easy and convenient way to get posted
right from your desk. A way to get
posted right from your desk. Yes.
Buy and print official US postage.
Using your own computer and printer.
No expensive postage meters, police
and no more trips to the post office.
You'll have to try it. You have
to try. I use stamps.com. Yeah,
sent out all my posters and then
I don't sell them after the show.
And then I got to use stamps dot. I'll
call him again to send them back home. Oh,
who's a dope. Sign up for
stamps.com and use my last name,
birth for this special four week
trial plus $110 bonus offer,
including postage and a digital scale.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before
you do anything else,
click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbirdthatstamps.com
enter
burr. Alright, let's knock
out these last few questions.
Come on,
help me out here.
Okay.
I fucking hate computers. They just
don't fucking work for me. All right,
there we go. All right. Baby's
mom is a whore. Jesus Christ,
Jesus Christ. Or as they say a
fucking hire. Um, get the chairs.
Get the hearts and the
chairs. All right, I'll,
I'll try and keep this
short and to the point,
I was dating a redheaded succubus
lady for almost eight years.
Uh,
what is succubus meet again?
This is the one who basically
takes over your life,
kills you afterwards.
I remember the South Park was the first
time ever heard that chef was warning
them about a succubus
succubus a female demon believed to have
sexual intercourse was sleeping men.
What?
Hmm.
And appears in dreams takes the
form of a woman in order to seduce,
been through sexual activity.
But then what does she
make you do afterwards?
Hang on a second.
Peers to take the form of the
male counterpart is the incubus.
Oh, is that how they got the name
for the band? Religious traditions
hold that repeated sexual activity
with the succubus may result in the
deterioration of health or even death.
I really don't see the downside to
any of that. All right? Let's, uh,
is supposed to be scary. It's
fucking great sleeping. She comes in,
she takes care of you. We need more
sucky business in the world. All right.
Her and I conceive Tucson's together.
Why do people date and have kids and
buy houses together and in that time we
were talking about getting married.
I loved her very much with all my hat.
We rented a house and live together
for most of our relationship.
I've always treated her with respect and
tried my best to be the best provider
for her and my two sons and her third
son whom she has with another guy.
Needless to say, she went out with the
girlfriends, which she had done many,
many of times before, but not did
not come home until the next day.
When I asked her why she stayed out all
night or it didn't call to let me know
what, what's up, she responded by telling
me she had sex with some random guy.
She met because she was drunk. I was
like, what the fuck? How could you,
why would you do that?
Her and I started to argue.
Then the course of the argument,
not only did I find out that she had
cheated on me, but in the entire time,
but in the entire time
her and I were together,
she just admitted to cheating on me
with 12 other people in our eight years
together.
What the fuck doesn't
quite put my feelings into
perspective and the only reason
she gave was the only reason she gave us.
She wasn't happy with me.
I don't understand that. And to this day
she still will not elaborate on that.
So I've since then moved out,
back home and my mom's,
I feel crushed like my entire life
was with her was a lie. It was,
she betrayed me in the worst possible way
and completely destroyed my outlook on
love. But not only that
I foe, but not only that,
I feel like I'm failing my family,
my kids,
and even that reddit and whore because
I couldn't keep my family together.
I've offered to go to
counseling now, dude, fuck that.
To try and work through this,
but she's not interested.
She acts like our eight years meant
nothing. It didn't mean nothing to her.
That doesn't mean you're a bad person.
She's been bouncing from guy to guy since
we split up those situations kind of
fucked up. Yeah. And you got
kids there and she doesn't care.
It's been several months now
and I still feel like shit. Uh,
I've been slang, bar sluts, right
and left, starting to work out,
trying to focus on bettering
myself and my sons lives.
Trying to keep my mind positive,
positively occupied.
But I still feel this pain in my chest.
Like something's missing her, I guess.
I don't know. Still Phil's
still feel lost his shit, dude.
All of that's totally normal. Um,
you supposed to feel that way.
Um, she probably doesn't feel anything
or maybe she does and that's why she's up
going around there. You know, fucking
everybody. Maybe she had an asshole dad.
I have no idea. Maybe she's a
succubus. I have no idea. Um,
the only way to get past this dude is
it continue doing what you're doing.
Go to the gym and I say, you got to
fuck every, warn them that moves.
But the only thing that
cures this is time, time.
And don't try to block it out,
dwell on it and cry it out of you.
All of that shit you're not supposed
to do as a guy. That's what women do.
They sit down,
they talk about it,
they cry it out and they get past it and
we fucking hang onto it forever and it
kills us.
So cry that bit shoddy you um,
you know,
is a big thing.
Never trash her to your kids because
as much as she fucked you over,
that's their mom,
you know,
and it's going to fuck them up and it's
going to make them pick the wrong kind
of woman or it's going to make them
treat women disrespectfully. So,
mmm.
I think what you gotta do is just,
you just did, it's all about you.
Now obviously you have kids,
but I would just try to become the best
guy you could and go meet a woman that's
worthy of being with you and then have
a great fucking life together and a,
you'll never need to trash your
wife in front of your kids.
They'll figure it out. They'll
figure it out. That's it.
And, uh, she trashes you and says
all this shit about you, just,
just be a great dad to a minute. It'll,
it'll, that aspect of it will work out.
But as far as like feeling lost, feeling
like a piece of shit, then, you know,
that just is how it goes. I mean, I had
that happen. I mean, I haven't had kids,
but I, you know, I had, I
women cheat on me. You know,
I've been an asshole. I've cheated
on women. I kind of gave an,
took equally in my dating history,
but uh,
you know, especially when
like I was younger and I
dated the fucking older woman.
She fucking ran around and I was an
idiot and then I was going on that good.
They're all fucking like that or
whatever. So whatever. You'll work it out.
All right. Time, travel, followup.
All right, this is the last one.
The podcast is done.
All right, Mr. Byrd, uh,
just now caught up with your podcast about
the time travel topic and thought you
might be interested in a few resources.
Last night there was a Chris Hardwick
show episode about the time travel story
that may have influenced your
writer or not. In any event,
the coincidence is interesting to me.
The Hardwick bid was based on the actual
candidacy for president of a man named
Andrew [inaudible] like Chicago.
Alright.
Mr [inaudible] claims to be the whistle
blower slash witness you would like to
hear come from any real
development program is
essentially claim is that he was
inducted into a deep black
military program. Uh,
there are many of these around the age
of six and discharge eventually at the
age of 23.
Then program develop physical and
modes of teleportation and time travel.
It's as easy to create an address for
a different time as a different place.
It turns out,
which was in service starting about 1967.
Yes. He says, I don't understand
what any of this shit,
I believe Mr Peshtigo testimony to be
truthful, so take that as you must.
But if you are interested in the story,
you should at least give some of his long
form interviews. Listen, I think, uh,
I think you can find them easily
by searching his name on Youtube.
Uh,
the quality of the interview views vary
a lot depending on the interviewers.
So if you get one when the interview
was annoyingly dumb, continue.
One of my favorites is this.
Here's the link. Just listen to,
just listen to the first four minutes
and see if you want to stop by. Right.
You know what I meant? I man, I love
this Scifi conspiracy theory shit.
I'll read it anytime you want.
All right. That's it. Uh,
if you could hear the kid
screaming next door, my apology,
if I had the recorded too
close to my gurgle and stomach,
I got to get some dinner before
I do my second show here. Um,
I apologize for that and big thank you
to everyone who came out to my show last
night and he had that kid
in Holland, uh, Amsterdam.
Unfortunately, I literally landed,
did the show and then had to leave.
I barely went by the van Gogh Museum.
Just saw it,
didn't get to go in. And
uh, I dunno. Would've been,
would've been great to hang
in such a great city of,
didn't in a chance to thanks
to everybody who came out, uh,
when I went through England. It's just
been a great tour. And, uh, so far,
one out of four shows has done here
in Scotland, and the first one was,
was as fun as shows you can have at four
o'clock in the afternoon as possible.
So that said, I'll check in
on you on Thursday. Go fuck
yourselves. I'll see you.